Now that we've finished
building the UI for our app,
it's time to think about
how it should operate
when it's not in the foreground.
One of the most powerful
features of Android,
is the ability for any app
to run in the background.
But with great power
comes great responsibility.
So you need to be very conscious
of how it's consuming resources.
In this lesson, you'll learn more about
how the Android framework
manages background apps.
And you'll be introduced
to the service class
to help make that happen.
You'll also learn techniques
for efficient data transfers
using sync adapters
and Google Cloud messaging.
And be introduced to the
notification framework
to send messages to your users
when your app isn't in the foreground.